A Pequena
Eva o nosso amor na
útima novos estudos revelam algo
incrível ivet não apenas impede a
replicação de mais de 18 tipos de vírus
incluindo aquele de 2019 mas também age
como a guardiã do nosso corpo
controlando a inflamação regulando o
sistema imune de maneira surpreendente é
como se ela soubesse exatamente onde
atacar para proteger o organismo o que a
torna uma esperança para quem sofre com
doenças autoimunes imagine o medicamento
com poder dos antiinflamatórios
tradicionais mas sem os efeitos
colateris que tantos temem e ainda tem
mais ela não só ajuda contra o vírus mas
também mostra força contra o câncer
freando o crescimento de células
tumorais e potencializando a
quimioterapia e pasm ela também pode ser
uma aliada no controle do diabetes